so trust in a company is not that
dissimilar from trust in our personal
relationships and and friendships you
know it's a human experience um it's a
feeling
um uh and as we've all experienced
during kovid it's more difficult to
build trust uh virtually it's not
impossible but it requires a lot more
work and a lot more intention you know
isaac stern the famous violinist
said music is what happens between the
notes well trust is what happens between
the meetings right it's the conversation
walking into the meeting in the
conversation walking out of the meeting
it's the bumping into somebody in the
hallway and being like oh i meant to
tell you
you know it's the hey you want to grab a
coffee that over the course of time
those those little moments of truth
those little innocuous experiences that
by themselves count from zero but over
time they start to build relationship
and they start to build trust the hard
thing in a virtual environment um is
those things are gone you don't have
between the meetings you only have the
meeting
and so
what you have to do is create those
opportunities artificially right
prescriptively um you have to force it
to happen so one easy thing to do that
we even we've embraced in our company is
a monday morning huddle
where
you know
it's encouraged that as many people show
up as possible of course if you have
client stuff you go do that but as many
people on an operating team come
together and uh and just check in with
each other
and it's not about work there's zero
discussion of work it's what's on your
heart and mind
and then we answer a funny or
provocative question that the whoever's
leading huddle that month will pose to
the team
and it's an opportunity for us to
connect as human beings where we say
this weekend was a hard weekend you know
my dad was admitted to hospital or this
weekend was a great weekend because i
got to spend some time with the kids i
didn't even know you had kids and we get
to see each other as human beings
and it's it goes a long way it's it
seems small and silly but over the
course of time we start to learn about
each other and see each other as people
rather than just as as co-workers and
you know or encouraging people to have
work sessions with each other where you
turn on facetime or zoom or something
and although you're not having a meeting
you just have them there while you're
doing your work or having drinks
together or you know i'm a huge fan of
using the telephone because i actually
think you can connect even better over
the telephone than
than sometimes over zoom
and like if you have an issue instead of
sending an email pick up the phone and
call somebody because very often you'll
solve the problem quicker and it's not
55 backwards and forwards but you'll
probably learn something new
and you can hear it in a voice which is
all
goes to building relationships so
we already know how to do it it's just a
matter of doing it